[Guitar riff]
I've been looking to  to sampling beats and and being able to curate music with those beats
♪ take it away ♪
It was a new experience, too, I'd never been in a studio before
♪ take me away♪
Yes! Yes, Rachel!
Through the workshop the mentors taught us how to produce music
on the computer and how to like work with sounds.
It felt like very inviting that they actually acknowledged like women of color.
[Applause]
It's so important to insure that the industry that I'm in reflects the world
that I live in. So for me it was very
important to take part in the Daughters
of Harlem Project
[music plays]
the project is called "For the Daughters
of Harlem: Working in Sound" and it
invites young women of color from New
York City's public schools to come to
Columbia and discuss, make, learn how to record, and produce their own music under
the guidance of workshop leaders
so the students are in the studio working with
professional equipment working with
professionals and it's collaborative
with each other so we have small groups
of students instead of one-on-ones they
rotate through the four instructors
throughout the day so everyone gets to
work with everyone else and in terms of
the second part it's a humanities based
workshop in which we want to bring some
ideas from scholarship to these young
women in a very real-life way so we were
inspired by a book called "Music in Everyday Life"
by Tia Donora who's a
sociologist so in that book she talks
about the uses of music and music as a
technology, music as a way that very
deeply intersects with one's idea of who
they are and who they can be
music to me is basically like how people express how they're feeling and like their emotions
but here is more about like sounds of
like everywhere so like music is like in
your daily life and you don't like
really know it so that's how I'm like
thinking about it differently here
that's what they've taught me
these instructors are amazing I'm really
interested in the music that they made
and the projects that they made as well. I  feel that's very creative and the
aspects that they have is very
intriguing and it's also making me
question what I'm trying to do with
those musical aspects so taking their
ideas is pretty unique
[ music plays] right so that's kind of what happens when it
when sampling is like brought into a musical session.
I kind of feel like because
Columbia is in Harlem I think that's why
this program is so necessary to be able
to reach out to the people of this
community and we've reached out a little
bit wider as well but it's it's super
rare and it's super needed I mean I'm
I'm well beyond their age but I feel
like I'm living through them and being
like yes there there are people like me
who do this and I do have a space in in
this industry so it's a great platform
it's it's confidence and it's that and
mindset that anything is possible, right? that, and not that anything is possible
that you are possible.
Yes Rachel!
There you go!
Yeah you just gotta listen to yourself. I know that like feeling, yeah.
I really love music so it was really encouraging to
work with someone who has experience and
it gave me an idea of how I want to be
creative and like the process and going
into producing and working with music
the scope and aim of the project was
sort of defined by a grant that we
applied for in mid-2017 and the granting
organization is an initiative that came
out of the Obama White House called
CATER, "the collaborative to advance
equity through research" and so the
mission of CATER really sort of fit what
professor in sama and I had been talking
about for a long time inequities and
barriers faced by women, by people of
color and particularly women of color
when it comes to particular kinds of
musical spaces, university spaces and
technologized spaces
I feel like it's
unique working with women especially
like if they look like you and they you
know they come from the same background
as you you can relate to other people
because of their backgrounds and because of what they listen to
it's really important I
think, early on, as early as possible for
children to see themselves represented
so it's really wonderful to have an
opportunity where the students can come
to Columbia University as high school
students and actually sit face-to-face
with one of the top-notch producers
engineers and songwriters in the country,
Ebony Smith, to be able to say, 'hey wait a
minute, she's doing this. I can do this'
I think it it enriches our industry to have
diversity along those lines to have
women in every facet of the business not
just in production engineering but also
in an AR and marketing and development
business development in legal-- it's so
important to ensure that the industry
that I'm in reflects the world that I
live in so for me it was very important
to take part in the Daughters of Harlem Project
Everybody knows what Columbia is
so for them to open up their doors for
us and to give us a chance, a chance that
we don't really get outside of here, is a
great and it makes me feel really
accepted and just comfortable and I know
the other women here can also agree
[Applause]